what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and here are 10 more things you
didn't know about eldon ring as a heads
up i'll be going over various things
from the lyrinia region so if you don't
want any spoilers from there you have
been warned celebus is secret after
finishing karya manor you'll find the
three sisters on the cliffside right
behind the manor the three sisters is
the name for the three towers all in
that small area renault's tower ronnie's
tower and celavus tower by entering
ronnie's tower you'll get a chance to
meet and discover the characters
secretly working for her blive war
master eg and selivus or as my co-worker
tam lovingly calls him celibus snape but
did you know that celebus has a secret
workshop you can find just outside of
ronnie's tower
in the rooms in front of ronnie's tower
you'll find a lone sorcerer this ruin
houses an illusory staircase leading to
a secret seller enceladus's workshop how
do i know this is celibace's workshop
outside of him being a loser creep he
literally tells you sullivan's puppets
do not touch
oh and his secret workshop has yet
another illusory wall within it showing
another puppet you might just recognize
black knife's illusory wall
it seems the luxury walls are one of
today's themes because i have yet
another one for you most dungeons in the
elden ring don't have illusory walls
trust me i hit practically every single
wall it's a compulsion i don't have a
wall checking phd for nothing but that
said there are enough occasional ones to
make it pay off and in particular within
leonia's black knife catacombs which can
be found here on the map this catacomb
threw me for a loop for one the fact you
have to ride up a trap in order to open
up the boss chamber creative and amazing
but for two there's not just one dungeon
boss in here but two for pulling the
lever you'll be able to find the
standard boss of the dungeon in this
case a cemetery shade
however
after you head up the trap into the
upstairs chamber and before you head
into the basement with the crabs and
levered to the normal boss there's
actually an illusory wall on the top
floor which will lead you to a black
knife assassin boss the assassin will
drop an assassin cerulean dagger which
is nice for some lore as well as the
fact that it allows critical hits to
restore your fp
but the real interesting find here is
the black knife print not only does it
have interesting lore tied to it but
it's also a quest item related to one of
the endings you can get when you finish
the game farming the big boy dragon
there's an easy way to get some fast
runes early in the game i'm talking
about big boy grail or at least that's
what i believe this dragon's name is in
grails dragon barrow you know given the
name of the area grail's dragon barrow
is pretty much as far east as you can
head on the map within caled it's
located right here on the map you have a
couple of options with grail if you want
you can find a spot where his guardian
baby dragons he spawns won't notice you
and you can take him out quietly getting
75 000 runes meanwhile if you use a gold
pickled foul foot it'll actually boost
how many runes you can get while it's
active meaning grail will instead give
you around 97 000 runes
you can also equip the gold scarab
talisman which has a similar effect to
the gold pickled foul foot to be honest
i don't know if these effects stack or
not but it's worth a shot this is
definitely a nice option if you're
struggling and want to get some quick
levels right off the bat however there
is another way to farm grail you see he
spawns guardian baby dragons constantly
while he's alive and one way to kill him
and the way i originally did is by
taking out these dragons with each kill
taking out a chunk of his life each of
these baby dragons you kill will give
you
5423 runes and while they hit hard once
you learn their pattern they really
aren't that difficult to kill and it
will simultaneously train you how to
kill just about every other dragon in
the game not only that but by resting
out a sight of grace with one right
nearby you're on a map if you're
wondering they respond and so does
grail's health that means that once you
get good at learning their pattern each
one is a nice and fairly quick way to
gain
5423 runes it is more time consuming
than methodically whittling away at him
which by the way using bleed will help
with but if you're really hurting for
runes it is worth thinking about
torrent back fighting i've talked about
illusory walls in rune farming so let's
go back to the basics i'm talking about
basic gameplay after playing years worth
of from software games i've gotten used
to the idea that your right trigger
buttons are related to your right-handed
weapons and your left trigger buttons
are related to your left-handed weapons
so when i finally got on torrent i
didn't even think to hit l1 or l2 as i
was trying to use my weapon
in fact i'm such a [ __ ] that i
practically played the entire game this
way so learn from me and my mistakes
while you're on torrent your left
trigger button acts as a way to swing to
the left of your horse that's right you
can do both light and strong attacks to
the left side you aren't just limited to
hitting to your right
i
am a [ __ ] double attacks while on
torrent and speaking of horseback combat
did you know that r2 and l2 or your
strong attacks on the horse can actually
get you multiple hits on enemies this is
an extremely useful tool i also didn't
use until much later in the game than i
care to admit while i knew that these
were stronger attacks i didn't realize
that you can actually get a double hit
with one attack while you're dragging
your weapon along the ground any enemy
you pass by will get hit by your weapon
when you let go of the trigger you'll
perform an upward strike also hurting
the enemy so if you time it out properly
that means you can hit the same enemy
with a quick one-two combo of dragging
your weapon then an upward slice attack
oh and while i'm at it with this when
you see mobs of enemies along the ground
why not run past them on torrent while
dragging your blade as you'll be able to
easily damage a giant group in one fell
swoop if you aim correctly as the drag
attack can hit any enemy that touches it
as you run by
spirit springs more like spirit wells
while i'm on this torn roll let's talk
about spirit springs
these are the gusts of air you'll see
all over the lands between that you can
use to launch torn high up in the air
and reach new locations or at the very
least climb up cliffs much quicker and
more conveniently than you'd otherwise
have to
but did you know that you can actually
jump right back down those spirit
springs and you'll survive the fall
meaning you can actually use them as a
convenient and quick way to travel down
cliffs that would otherwise kill you
from the drop and not just use them to
travel up the more you know
torrents and status effects i'm going to
continue with even more info on torrent
because torrent is a king and kings
deserve to be loved especially if
they're the elden lord and they're me
mainly i'm just talking about me
one of the many amazing things about
torrent is that riding him will help you
avoid picking up status effects from any
poison rot or other ground ailments feel
free to run over rivers of rot and
poison while on torrent without a worry
in the world except for being knocked
off of him also be careful as status
effects in the air can still hit and
affect you of course you can't use
torrent and dungeons so this won't work
for every situation but it is nice to
know and speaking of situations where
you're torrentless do not roll in poison
hiratake miyazaki loves poison so much
so i wouldn't be surprised if his home
was built in a poison swamp surrounded
by a moat of scarlet rot
so is suffice to say there's a lot of
boys in the melton ring and one thing
you do not want to do
is roll in the poison i know that may
sound obvious but in a game where dodge
rolling is an important mechanic you're
bound to forget this or be forced into
it if you roll in poison or scarlet rot
your clothing will be covered in it and
the effect will continue to build up on
you until you either clean yourself off
in water or naturally dry off this isn't
a new element to elven ring we've seen
it in previous from software games but
it's still worth noting
that annoying glinting item in the
stranded graveyard
at the very very start of the game right
after the introduction you'll find
yourself in the stranded graveyard
you'll probably run out of here pretty
quickly to go explore limgrave or
perhaps drop down to do the tutorial but
if you look behind you there's an item
there that's annoyingly out of reach
so how in the world do you get it and
what is it
well i'm here to tell you how this one
was actually tweeted to me by psy
rainfire on twitter so major props to
you sai and thank you for helping me
find this warped to the seaside cliffs
site of grace and lim grave this site of
grace is just south of the stranded
graveyard west of the dragonburn ruins
and agile lake or here on a map next
you're going to need to drop down to the
beach just west of you watch out as most
places you choose to drop will cause you
to die from fall damage if you look down
there is a spot with some raised rubble
and you'll need to drop down here from
there going down shouldn't be too much
trouble and you'll find an alabaster
lord who drops the ash of war gravitas
upon his defeat
now that you're on the beach keep
heading north and eventually you'll find
a cave this cave leads directly into the
back side of the stranded graveyard and
to the mysterious item a hallog drake
talisman the halic drag talisman boosts
your resistance to holy damage when it's
equipped
nice
those statues with glints in them have
you noticed the statues that have item
glints in them you know like the one on
stormhill near all of the trolls or
perhaps the one near the end of
stormville castle well these are good
very very good they pretty much always
contain a whole slew of smithing stones
inside and all you need to get them is a
very big enemy while it doesn't have to
be a troll for these two examples i'll
use a troll
up top on storm hill beta troll into
hitting the statue and you'll unlock all
of its goodies meanwhile in stormville
you'll have to get the troll hanging out
by godric to notice you chase you down
all the way back to the statue and then
bait him into attacking it there are
plenty more statues like these so keep
your eyes peeled for them and make sure
to bait a big enemy into breaking them
for you
that does it for this week's 10 things i
hope you learned something new if you
missed it i made an episode last week
focusing on lim grave and we'll have a
new episode on 10 more things for you
next week thanks so much for watching
and i'll see you guys soon for more
elden ring content peace